Copenhagen is the capital of Denmark
festa borough was a red-light district
but now it's a trendy neighborhood many
young people work here
there are many cafes what's said to be
the world's smallest hotel is located
over the cafe central may think Feb came
up with the idea of converting an empty
room on the second floor once home to a
shoemaker now it's a hotel room you can
find many hotels in the world you can
pay a lot of money you can find very
luxury hotels but you don't really want
to stay there at night you don't want to
stay in and this is use of Danish word
hookah which is like cozy it's warm it's
it's nice to stay in and so that's the
plan I mean this is a room you don't
want to leave the idea has taken off the
hotel in a building dating back to 1905
has been open since June it's almost
always booked despite a price of 200
euros per night the small room was
lovingly furnished with optimized use of
space the room comes with the iPhone
which is a yeah with the the guest can
use we have the TV TV screen in here
behind so it looks nice and easy
yeah there's a little film for
downstairs for the cafe if you are
having guests at the room you can of
course check out the table so you can
set my phone person there to hear well
of course the very important thing the
minibar which is also very nice
guests should feel right at home even
though it's small there's still an
ensuite shower and in the evening when
the cafe is closed they have the whole
house to themselves
it's a really beautiful hotel it's
really sort of quirky and interesting
and very individual you can really see
the kind of vibe of the guy who runs it
and owns it and how much care is taken
and it's a really beautiful is like most
being in the ship's cabin or something
very cozy at night and yeah it's really
wonderful we've had a fantastic time
initially leaf thing feds only wanted to
open a cafe it's his specialty
he has another cafe a larger one right
around the corner neighbors and hotel
guests meet and mix their gatherings are
cosmopolitan
last week we had we had guests from
Canada we have guests from Japan and
Kazakhstan quite fun yeah
so it's worldwide and what may be the
world's smallest hotel has also become a
tiny cozy oasis in downtown Copenhagen